foreign
[Music]
with Deadpool Venom and Loki Marvel
already has very popular anti-heroes in
its Universe what the MCU is still
lacking however is a counterpart to DC's
Suicide Squad but that is set to hit
theaters in 2024. the talk is of the
Thunderbolts the group consists of
several characters all of whom we have
already had the pleasure of seeing in
the one or other Marvel production the
movie will be the conclusion of Phase 5
of the MCU so it's likely not that
unimportant for the franchise in order
to keep you up to date we have put
together all the known information about
the cast production and plot in this
video enjoy
the cast around the Thunderbolts is
mostly known and has some familiar names
ready but new actors are also joining
the MCU for this film
first let's take a closer look at the
eponymous Thunderbolts the group is led
by Allegra de Fontaine played by Julia
Louis-Dreyfus we already know her from
the Falcon and the Winter Soldier in the
2020 series there are already early
references to the Thunderbolts as de
Fontaine is apparently trying to recruit
people with special abilities in the
final episode she also recruits the
second member of the group John Walker
played by Wyatt Russell the character
has had a rather tragic part thus far
Walker was also initiated the super
soldier syrup and was meant to take over
Captain America's Legacy sadly with his
ego he mostly gets in his own way
leaving Sam Wilson AKA Falcon to take
over the role still Walker has similar
powers to cap though not as
sophisticated yet he is not the only
character around Captain America which
will play a part in the Thunderbolts
Cap's best friend Bucky Barnes is also
involved again embodied by Sebastian
Stan how Walker and Bucky will work
together is yet to be seen after all the
two battled each other in the Falcon and
the Winter Soldier besides buggy is
known more as a loner than a team player
he is a gift to do a list especially
with his mechanical arm a black widow
will also join the group namely
Natasha's sister Yelena Bulova the last
time we saw Elena was in Hawkeye where
she wanted to take revenge on Clint
Barton as she blames him for Natasha's
death her powers are comparable to her
sisters even though Natasha was the more
powerful of the two Elena is again
played by the British actress Lawrence
Pugh her Mentor Red Guardian is also
part of the movie so we can expect a
fair amount of humor as well the Red
Guardian is primarily known for his
strength it remains to be seen whether
he will fit better into his suit again
since the movie Black Widow the Red
Guardian is again played by stranger
things Star David Harbor beside Jelena
and the Red Guardian another character
from Black Widow has made it to the
Thunderbolts while she was an antagonist
in the 2021 film she is now one of their
allies we're talking about Taskmaster
her real name is Antonia drakoff she is
the daughter of the Russian general who
controls the Red Room he has brainwashed
his own daughter and modified her in a
way that her only mission is to
eliminate enemies she is particularly
assisted in this task by an inserted
microchip it allows her to imitate all
of her opponent's movements Taskmaster
is again played by Ukrainian model Olga
kurilenko the last member we can look
forward to is ghost who we already know
from Ant-Man and the WASP ghost whose
real name is Ava Starr got her
superpower in an accident when an
experiment on the quantum realm failed
her parents died before her eyes Ava
survived however and was dematerialized
from now on she can move through objects
at will and turn invisible she is once
again played by Hannah John Cayman a new
actor is being cast for the role of
General Ross since the former actor
William Hurt passed away in 2022 as in
Captain America 4 his role will be
assumed by none other than Harrison Ford
a key role will be played by Walking
Dead star Stephen Yu who joined the cast
in February 2023 however nothing
official is known about his role yet one
Marvel character associated with his
name is the Sentry AKA Robert Reynolds
Reynolds is considered one of the
strongest superheroes in the comics he
also gets the super soldier's hero which
grants him the power of a thousand
exploding Sons this allows him to
effortlessly take on Fighters like the
Hulk Thor or Carnage however he has a
very unstable psyche which is why he
usually tries to stay out of trouble or
not fight with full force well actually
he is one of the good guys so if the
character choice for Steven Yoon really
falls on Sentry we are excited to find
out what Marvel will make of the
superhero after all nothing is known
about an antagonist in Thunderbolt just
yet also new to the MCU is Ayo adibiri
the American actress most recently had a
speaking part in Spider-Man across the
spider-verse she also stars in the
series The Bear whose second season has
just begun on Disney plus nothing is
known about her role in Thunderbolts yet
in a statement though it can be read
that she will take on a rather small
part
one big question fans are wondering
regarding the cast is where is Daniel
Brule in the role of Baron Zemo he has
an important role in the comics when it
comes to the Thunderbolts so far however
there's not been any official word on
whether Daniel Brule will be returning
to his role zemo's character was last
explored further in the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier there he revealed his
profound hatred for superheroes by
looking for ways to kill the flag
Smasher super soldiers it all looked
promising for a major future in the MCU
therefore it seems reasonable for us to
assume that he will appear in one form
or another in Thunderbolts in light of
zemo's particular righteous anger
towards superheroes that would make
perfect sense
since we sadly have nothing to share
with the plot at the moment let's take a
closer look at the Thunderbolts comic
book original and compare it to its
counterpart from the dceu the
Thunderbolts similar to The Suicide
Squad are not a typical superhero team
they are made up of unconventional
individuals who wouldn't be considered
to be heroes in the first place The
crucial difference though lies in their
motive while the suicide squad is
literally forced to complete dangerous
missions with little chance of survival
the Thunderbolts have a common goal
their initiator is Baron helmet Zemo a
criminal strategist and Nemesis of
Captain America he came up with the idea
of reforming criminals and presenting
them to the public as Heroes originally
formed as the masters of evil the group
become unemployed after the Earth's
Heroes were nearly wiped out Zemo saw an
opportunity to establish superhero teams
in order to manipulate the public for
more power he recruited a first team
including Goliath fixer Screaming Mimi
Beetle and Moonstone under new
identities such as citizen V Atlas
techno Songbird Mach 1 and meteorite the
villains disguise themselves as Heroes
however the most planned for global
domination evolved into an unexpected
twist when his team members actually
became Heroes and settled their debt to
society After zemo's Fall numerous
well-known characters from the Marvel
Universe became part of the
thunderbolt's family at various points
in Time characters like Deadpool
Abomination Whiplash Venom Norman
Osborne and many others spent their time
with the Thunderbolts as well as most of
the characters now announced for the
planned movie adaptation even some
established Heroes like Hawkeye America
Chavez and Spectrum were at times part
of the team or even part of the current
Squad interestingly Zemo himself also
joined the group sometimes actually
reforming but mostly returning to his
roots as a villain this Dynamic team and
the multitude of characters clearly
offer plenty of potential for an
action-packed and exciting movie or even
more
Jake schreier will direct Thunderbolts
in 2012 schreier Drew attention to
himself with the critically acclaimed
film Robot and Frank and three years
later enjoyed great success with the
book adaptation of Paper Towns the
screenplays penned by two authors at
once first by Eric Pearson who already
worked on the MCU Productions Thor
Ragnarok and black widow and the other
writer is Lee sung Jin who most recently
worked on the Netflix series beef sung
Jin voiced his excitement about working
with Jake schreier again who was
likewise involved in beef there in turn
Stephen Yoon played one of the main
roles who has now also been cast in
Thunderbolts so we can expect an already
well coordinated team however filming
has not yet begun and will be postponed
for the time being due to the actor
strike in fact the movie was supposed to
be released in July 2024 but has been
pushed back to December 20th 2024. we'll
have to wait and see if this is indeed
the date that the movie will hit
theaters
that was all the information we had on
the Thunderbolts were you already
familiar with them or
the MCU turned to its former glory and
which villain would you like to see on
the big screen let us know in the
comments down below
[Music]
foreign